good morning and welcome to NASA
headquarters I'm NASA press secretary
Jackie McGinnis and thank you for
joining us to announce who NASA will
work with to develop a human Landing
system for the agency's Artemis 5
Mission to the Moon
NASA issued the solicitation for the
Lander known as appendix p in September
of 2022 as part of the ongoing
development of advanced space
exploration Technologies capabilities
and Concepts we're joined today by NASA
administrator Bill Nelson
Jim free associate administrator for the
exploration systems development mission
directorate
Lisa Watson Morgan program manager for
NASA's human Landing system and we'll
also hear from a couple company
representative before answering your
questions but first I'll hand it over to
administrator Nelson
good morning everybody
just over two years ago
NASA announced that SpaceX would build a
human Landing system to deliver the
first astronauts to the lunar surface
it's been a half century since we were
there
we held a robust competition for the
first landing
and SpaceX is making good progress
we have big goals for our Artemis
program
about a mission a year to the lunar
surface for stays for our astronauts up
to 30 days
and today's announcement is about
maintaining that Cadence
it's about maintaining our Excellence as
the world's top Space Program
and to maintain that for generations to
come
it's about maintaining collaboration
with our industry Partners who will
enable
generations of explorers and Pioneers to
live and work on other planets
so we're here today to make an exciting
announcement about a second Lander award
an additional different Lander
will help ensure that we have the
hardware necessary for a series of
Landings
to carry out the Science and Technology
development on the surface of the Moon
and that
what we do on the surface of the Moon is
in preparation for us to go to Mars
I've said it before
we want more competition
we want two Landers
and that's better
and it means that you have reliability
you have backups
it benefits NASA it benefits the
American people
these are public private Partnerships
it's the new way that we go to the Moon
it helps NASA share the risk the
technical risk and the Financial Risk
the cost
to enable
at the end of the day Mission success
this new Lander will be built and
operated according to NASA's
sustaining lunar lander requirements
which needless to say when you put
astronauts in that environment
those requirements are vigorous
those capabilities include docking with
Gateway the many some call lunar Space
Station
it includes increased crew capacity
it includes transporting more cargo for
Science and exploration on the moon's
surface
and so today we NASA
announced that blue origin
and partners Lockheed Martin Draper
Boeing
astrobotic and honeybee robotics
will build a human Landing system to
deliver NASA astronauts to the lunar
surface
for the Artemis five mission
NASA's SLS rocket will launch for
astronauts
to lunar orbit aboard Orion
they'll transfer to the Gateway before
entering blue Origins blue moon lander
for about a week-long trip to the South
Pole
and there they will conduct science and
exploration activities
our partnership will only add to this
golden age of human space flight
our work with commercial and
international Partners is keeping people
fixated on the stars and if you doubt
this International
aspect just look how we were received a
month ago when we went
to Ottawa Canada
received by the Canadian government
because the first foreign astronaut on
Artemis 2 to the Moon is a Canadian
astronaut
they are eager
to be our partner and that is true
across the globe
the historic Artemis one test flight six
months ago was a huge success
in Houston last month we saw firsthand
the progress that Axiom space is making
on the spacesuits and those are the ones
that our astronauts will wear on the
moon
SpaceX is working hard on their starship
and Lander which will deliver the first
woman and the next man to the surface
I've asked and I still ask Jim free
every day how we are doing on the
schedule for Artemis 2
and he assures me that we are on track
for
the fall of 2024.
and with today's announcement
we are making an additional investment
in the infrastructure that will pave the
way to land the first humans on Mars
it's an incredible moment in space
flight history
it's been 61 years since President
Kennedy's words reverberated through
rice stadium and made their way into the
history books
now we know the first part
quote
we go to the moon in this decade and do
other things not because they are easy
but because they are hard
but he continued
because that goal will serve to organize
and measure the best of our energies and
skills
because that challenge is one that we
are willing to accept
one we are unwilling to postpone
and one in which we intend to win
our shared Ambitions now are no less
lofty
than when President Kennedy dared a
generation of dreamers to Journey to the
Moon
and so today in this school an era of
exploration the Artemis generation
NASA chooses to return to the Moon
together
with our commercial partners
with our International partners
and together
our work will pave the way for
astronauts to one day venture to Mars
that Jackie
thank you
[Applause]
thank you administrator before we go to
our next speaker I want to welcome some
of our partners from Blue origin to join
us here in the auditorium
[Applause]
and next we'll hear from Jim free
thank you Jackie good morning everybody
it's a great honor to join you here this
morning and and welcome our new teammate
to this side of the Artemis program in
blue origin and congratulate you on your
um your award
um as the administrator mentioned uh
this Lander is targeted for Artemis five
which is really the intersection of our
our test flight and our long-term plans
but I'd like to kind of talk to you
about the other missions and then talk a
little bit more specific on five so the
administrator talked about Artemis one
an incredible Flawless Mission I think
we've used a lot of superlatives around
it and all of them well earned and the
data that we have from that mission is
informing our next one which uh the crew
being here in DC the past two days I've
only heard the stories of them I haven't
seen them but the stories certainly have
gotten around about an incredible crew
that will fly an Artemis too test out
our Eclipse systems fly around the moon
and really give us that confidence to
fly Crews on every Mission thereafter
um as the administrator also mentioned
Artemis 3 will have the SpaceX Lander on
it and the Axiom suits critical
developments for us returning humans to
the Moon where we'll have those humans
to explore that history that is the
South Pole four and a half billion years
of solar system history uh right there
on the moon and we use the cruise
decision-making skills and dexterity to
really get samples to bring back for our
science Mission directorate Partners to
uh to use and explore further and I
always told Thomas or book and he opened
that last sample last year of the Apollo
program I think to challenge us to get
back there sooner so the The Gauntlet
has been laid down
an Artemis 4 that really
critical test flight where we bring on
the exploration upper stage our
co-manifested payload capability where I
have our International partner the
European space agency and and jaxa with
the ihab module continuing to build our
capability where we'll go to Gateway for
the first time and use gate Gateway and
the SpaceX Lander built to the
sustainable Lander requirements to go
down to the surface and uh and bring the
crew safely back home and then finally
Artemis five uh what which we're talking
about the Lander for today where we'll
really get to that yearly Cadence of
missions that's our goal is to be at
that yearly Cadence with Artemis five
we'll take up the Esprit module in the
co-manifested payload space with the
crew and that's again provided by the
European space agencies or International
Partners continue to grow there we'll
have the crew transfer from Orion to
Gateway and then into the blue origin
Lander and go down to the surface this
Lander much like the space sex second
Lander will have those sustainable
Lander requirements to allow our crews
eventually to stay up to 30 days as we
build up the infrastructure
which is all based on our Moon to Mars
objectives long term our objectives
we're trying to prove out at the Moon to
go on to Mars and around which we built
our recently released architecture
so I'd like to take a minute just to
thank the NASA team that worked on this
procurement for the the past year plus
um it's an incredible daunting job it's
a lot of work and I'd like to personally
thank the folks from across the agency
led by the folks at Marshall but folks
across the agency that supported that so
I would like to thank our NASA team
with that congratulations again to our
blue origin partner that joins us on
this side of the Artemis program you
know for me being part of the Artemis
team is a great honor but it comes with
great responsibility
I hope that you share that honor today
and I look forward to you sharing that
responsibility in the future with that
let me turn it back over to Jackie
[Applause]
thanks Jim now we'll hear from Lisa
Watson Morgan
foreign
and thank you administrator Nelson it
really is just the culmination of of so
many months it's so exciting to be here
so much work you know with all of our
cross program
entities with Orion and SLS and and the
ground system at KSC Gateway
um suits it's it's really a pleasure to
be here and to really see us take this
next step
so today's announcement it is an
important and exciting next step for the
human Landing System Program and now we
will have two providers and providing
that competition that the administrator
talked about earlier it also helps us
with then a more Diversified industrial
base and that will help us Advance
innovation in the future and that's
really part of the American dream
I'm grateful for the continued strong
Congressional and stakeholder support
for the human Landing System Program you
know it shows that they're with us that
we're all together as a nation as we
approach our return to the Moon
we are really excited today to be
working with blue origin and all of
their partners
we definitely have confidence in them
and their approach
they have a very exciting architecture
with a reusable blue origin Lander and
Lockheed Martin CIS lunar transporter as
well as lots of other contributions from
their other partners
with two Lander Pathfinder test flights
scheduled in the next few years I really
look forward to working with them on how
all that testing is going to help
contribute to the overall development
and our mission success
and our teams will soon perform a
kickoff where we get together we get to
dig in deeper to all the details and the
plan and that will that will get us
started on the execution of the Artemis
5 Mission and and that's what we're all
about we're definitely about execution
uh and and getting started now I also
want to say it's the the Lander system
and the programs Artemis and all of all
of the efforts on Moon to Mars
what we are trying to do is build on the
lessons of the past and I do want to
take a moment to say earlier this week
at the Johnson Space Center I was able
to meet with Charlie Duke a former
Apollo astronaut
and we heard from his lips what it is
like
the the hurdles we have to overcome some
of the things maybe we didn't think
through and how all that will affect our
implementation and I'm telling you that
was such a gift
and with that knowledge and the
experience base that we gain from
listening to him and to others we're
building a stronger future that will
help us be successful on the South Pole
and in our sustaining efforts
so with that I just want to say thank
you and I'm really excited to get
started
[Applause]
thanks Lisa next we'll hear from John
caloris blue Origins vice president for
lunar Transportation who will be
overseeing Lander development and is
joining us virtually John
good morning everyone
thank you again for this incredible
opportunity on behalf of blue origin and
the national team I want to thank NASA
personally we're very honored and
humbled to be part of this incredible
experience uh we're looking forward to
participating on Artemis 5 and we're
looking forward to working together this
national team has been working together
for a number of years and we're really
maturing our efforts now and we're very
excited about the appendix P effort
the blue origin blue moon lunar lander
is uh configured in two configurations
the first configuration is a crew
configuration that will be able to land
four astronauts anywhere on the surface
of the Moon day or night that'll be the
first mission that we fly as part of
Artemis five
this Vehicles also can be configured for
a cargo Landing Mission able to carry up
to 20 metric tons in a round trip a
reusable configuration or 30 metric on a
surface to form the foundation of
habitats and other permanent
infrastructure
uh as part of a national team we're very
fortunate to have Lockheed Martin who's
building the CIS lunar transporter the
assist learner transporter will provide
refueling services from low earth orbit
to nrho and the parking orbit of where
our Lander is located
along with the team is Draper who will
be doing GNC navigation and also our
training and simulation we've also
brought new members to the national team
astrobotic who will be doing our cargo
accommodations honeybee robotics will be
doing our cargo offloading capability
and Boeing who will be doing our docking
systems so once again thank you very
much we've been working very hard for
this day and we're very little we're
looking forward to working together and
we want to also give thanks for uh the
incredible effort during appendix age
and how appendix and and working
together with NASA was able to get all
of all the competitors together and
ready for appendix p thank you
thanks John
[Applause]
so now it's time to answer your
questions we'll take both questions over
the phones and here in the room if you'd
like to ask a question on the phone just
a reminder to please press one star one
to get into the queue
uh first up we have a question in the
room from Joey roulette with Reuters
uh thanks um and congrats to Blue origin
what's the value of the contract and how
much money is blue origin putting into
it
John
uh certainly so um the total evaluated
price will come out I will say that blue
origin are Endeavors to make human
permanence on the moon is uh been part
of our core beliefs or sometimes so we
want to establish permanence on the moon
and we want to ensure that we have uh
consistent access to the moon so with
that in mind uh blue origin itself is
contributing uh over 50 percent of uh
the total effort to get to uh not only
this Mission but to ensure permanence
can you can you say how much the
proposal was or what you think the award
might be
as far as value
I'm sorry I didn't hear that question
John he's asking how much the award was
for
and I
our team can
Jim do you want to jump in yeah I mean
the uh you'll see it in the
documentation that's released but the
award was about three and a half billion
dollars uh NASA award
thanks
thanks Joey next up in the room we have
Jeff Faust with space news uh good
morning
um wondering if anyone from NASA can say
how many uh bids it received for this
and what about the blue origin uh
proposal stood out that caused you to
select it thank you
we evaluated uh two proposals for the
competition and uh I I would say the
selection statements gonna come out here
shortly I encourage you to take a look
at that for the specifics Jeff
phones we have Irene klotz with Aviation
week
um thanks we can't hear any of the
questions or the answers by the way so
sorry if this is redundant but could you
say again the value of the award and
what it covered as far as test flights
and also if there was any how many
proposals did NASA review for the hls
sustaining work thank you
so I just want to check in with Brad our
operator about the technical
difficulties I want to make sure our
folks on the phone can hear
the value of the award was 3.4 billion
dollars and John said they're
contributing about
more than 50 50 over 50 percent
Brad just want to double check though
sorry that that our folks can hear us
okay
um
next I'll take a question from the room
Michael sheets with CNBC
thank you very much I believe this
question is best for NASA I'm still in
the contract value I want to make sure I
understand correctly because previously
blue origin had said that they would be
willing to fund up to three billion
dollars themselves so am I understanding
correctly that this is effectively a six
billion dollar combined development
effort and secondarily is the Artemis
five mission still planned for 2029
thank you
so
yeah so so uh it is we're still planning
five Artemis five for 2029
um and and the the award was just over
3.4 billion and I think it's uh its blue
Origins uh I know they've given you the
50 number they can they can be more
specific on the total dollar value
amount
John can you create a comment on that
yeah hey Mike um so that's correct uh
blue origin is uh is contributing uh
well north of 3.4 billion dollars as
part of this effort thank you very much
thanks we'll take our next question from
the phones Eric Berger with ours
Technica
I guess my question is about NASA's
budget priorities you know we saw a
great flight of the SOS rocket
um late last year and so that's that's
going to be flight proven and now kind
of a long poll on these lunar Landings
is the actual Landers and it seems like
your budget for lunar Landers is about
the same as the the rocket over the next
five years
and so I'm just wondering you know
administrator or or Mr free you know do
these budget priorities really reflect
the urgency necessary and sort of
getting getting to the lunar surface
because you know the Rocket's there and
then the lunar Landers are are still a
long way to go thank you
both the Congress and the Office of
Management and budget
have been very generous with us
in making sure that we have the Landers
and
that we have two Landers
that has not been an easy task
but I want to give the shout out to both
of them they recognize that that's what
is needed
now if I understand your question
is that provided in our budget the
answer is yes
and I think the announcement here today
where
the successful bidder is putting in over
50 percent more skin in the game than
what the NASA contract
fixed price contract is is quite
significant
and it underscores the fact that this
public-private partnership that we go
back to the Moon
uh is in fact working
it's worked in the first uh instance as
I said at the outset of my remarks with
SpaceX
and they likewise put in a lot of skin
in the game
and that mission for the first Lander is
proceeding on schedule
and likewise in the announcement of this
award today you're seeing a similar
situation
that would clearly indicate the wisdom
of this public-private partnership
thank you take care
I'm rocoda for a Japanese national
newspaper section I was wondering if you
could provide the test schedule for blue
moon or when and how do you plan to test
it thank you
for John would you mind elaborating on
the testing schedule for the Lander
sure thanks for the question so uh
working backwards if you will at before
the first crew Landing occurs we will be
landing a exact uh copy of that Lander
prior to that one year prior so we'll be
testing out full Lander systems and the
full architecture prior to any
astronauts uh entering the vehicle and
that'll be roughly one year prior
before that we have a number of test
launches and landings that will be uh
we'll be releasing here soon but as Lisa
made reference we do have our Blue Moon
mark one Landers that uh we are
currently uh posting uh flight hardware
for you may have seen it on social media
and the team's very excited about
working those to prove Technologies for
these future Landers before crew members
even step inside
thanks John we'll take our next question
from the phones we have Alicia sours
from Mashable
hi thank you um this is a question for
Mr caloris hopefully I will be able to
hear his answer
um
there have been three straight Landing
failures with um the Beret sheet and the
chandrian and now ice-based missions
all previous uh private Landers that I'm
aware of have failed and that's not a
great track record so what makes you
confident that you can achieve this
especially when there are humans
involved thank you
yes thanks for the question can you hear
me okay we can hear you yes I can hear
you now thank you okay okay so um as I
made reference to we will be actually uh
Landing a number of vehicles prior to uh
crew actually uh
um landing on the moon utilizing our
vehicles so not only will we be testing
the Technologies in the lunar
environment to ensure safety uh but then
those will migrate into these Landers
they will also fly as I mentioned a
complete uh for the complete version of
the lunar lander in an uncrewed fashion
one year prior to check out all systems
we'll then launch a new Lander for crew
members to go on board I'd also like to
mention
um that's one of the great things about
the national team a blue origin has been
working these Landers for a number of
years Lockheed Martin brings extensive
experience on Landers as well as their
work on Orion Draper astrobotic and
honeybee are fantastic partners and
they're part of the clips Awards Boeing
as well with their experience on ISS and
what they bring to the team it's kind of
like a perfect blending of what we're
trying to do of lessons learned so we
don't repeat those lessons again
hey and Jackie can I add something to
that please yeah and I also want to add
that there's also the NASA inside and
the experience base that I mentioned in
some of my earlier comments and we're
working towards human rating
requirements and you know as you saw
from the Artemis one launch we fully
understand those so working together
collectively we can bring the best from
the government side and our years of
experience with with their experience
and and we do believe it will be
successful
thank you very much we'll take our next
question from the phones we have a
Christopher quickness with astronomy
magazine
yes thank you can you hear me okay we
can hear you
okay great thank you um this is I guess
a question for John
um maybe getting a little more specific
about the test uh schedule or sort of
flow of tests
um is there the possibility or um are
you planning for accrued uh mission in
Blue Moon that is Earth orbitable Earth
orbital
um before you actually do the crude
landing on the moon
uh thanks for your question it's a great
question
um the first time that crew members will
enter the Lander will be when it's
docked to Gateway the crew members will
um go to Gateway via Orion and then
transfer to Lander for operations
between nrho and the lunar surface and
then back to Gateway
okay thank you so
um so that will actually be the Artemis
five mission will be the first time crew
are in it
that's correct that's correct and we
have as we mentioned all these
demonstration missions prior to that
leading up to that mission
great thanks thank you very much
thank you sir thank you both our next
question on the phone is from Micah
maidenberg with Wall Street Journal
um it's been
how will blue and its Partners get you
know if Landers out to the moon for the
the test missions and leader uh to
Gateway for Artemis five thanks
certainly so we utilize uh our new Glenn
launch vehicle for all of our components
uh both the Lander to go to nrho as well
as assist lunar transporter and then uh
follow-on refueling flights
thank you both
our next question on the phones is from
Alan Boyle with geekwire
a couple of questions maybe the feeling
from the gaps in my understanding I
think uh I think it was mentioned that
there would be a couple of Pathfinder
flights uh and so there's the one that
happens a year before the crude flight
and I think previously uh blue origin
had talked about how this was perhaps
going to land in the vicinity of where
the crude Landing might take place and
it might be possible to send some cargo
that could be used during the crude
Mission uh so that's that's one
issue that I wanted to find out is
whether that was still the plan and then
are there other Pathfinder flights that
would be flown before that uncrewed
lunar Landing or are you referring
perhaps to a SpaceX Pathfinder flight
for example thank you
yeah thanks for the question now so um
anyway this will come out as part of the
award but blue origin will be landing uh
two Landers prior to the Mark II Lander
that will demonstrate single string
operations avionics be7 reaction control
system Etc uh to this uh right now South
Pole of the Moon then uh after those two
missions we'll fly the first uncrewed uh
Mission as part of this award in
appendix p and return that to nrho that
goes and that's that's worth noting
because right now that's above and
beyond the uh appendix P requirements of
Just Landing we're actually are going to
lift off and bring it back to nrho and
then we'll launch a new Lander that will
then carry crew to the surface
thank you our next question on the
phones is from Bill Harwood with CBS
News
yeah hi thanks um John can you give us
any ballpark on the mass of the Lander
the Mark II Lander that's going to carry
astronauts uh just just to give us a
sense of that in any Dimensions you
might have off the top of your head uh
to Ballpark it and out of curiosity
what's going to happen to the unpowered
Lander that you the full-up Lander that
you test before the astronauts come is
that simply discarded or is it in some
way can it be used again thanks
sure great question thanks I'll work
backwards
um the first Lander could be utilized
again uh we're right now using that as
purely risk reduction so that our uh
efforts are not dependent on that Lander
but it could absolutely be uh utilized a
second time uh the Lander is optimized
for our seven meter fairing of new Glenn
so we specifically optimize
um height and mass for uh new Glenn
um and then Mass uh will be part of the
release when we get into that because uh
it depends of course on which Mission
and so forth
um the the important points as you can
see here in the graphic because this is
now a sustainable Lander uh the appendix
P requirements allowed us to look back
at the original appendix age and say
okay if we want to re if we want to
emphasize robust reliable low-cost
operations what would how would we
structure that Lander and it was an
integrated Lander and as you can see
it's an integrated Lander that now
allows crew access to the surface
not only rapid access to the surface but
then also scales for future efforts such
as a lunar terrain vehicle or habitats
where perhaps those could dock directly
to the Lander crew module and not
require an Eva to transfer from the
vehicle to one of these uh permanently
put in place assets so that's why we're
proud of this Lander and as you can see
it's an integrated Lander so that the
entire system can be reused and then
land again in a different location in
the Moon
thanks John our next question on the
phone comes from Leo Enright with Irish
TV
thanks very much for doing this I guess
this is probably for the administrator I
was just wondering you mentioned
Eastbury the European space agency's
refueling Communications modules going
up on this flight uh do you envisage a
European astronaut going on this Mission
and do you envisage that European
astronaut walking on the moon
you're way ahead
with that question
the Canadian astronaut is going on
Artemis 2.
on Artemis 3 which is the first landing
of the four crew members two will
descend to the surface
we expect that will be the first woman
and the next man to land on the moon now
obviously that crew has not been
selected the crew that's been selected
is the one that's in DC right now
uh
by the way to rave reviews
as the crew of Artemis 2 which will
Circle the Moon
so when will foreign astronauts join
on the actual Landing
that's much further down the road
but likely it would not be on Artemis 3
on the first landing that is expected
the first woman in the first man would
both be Americans
thank you our next question on the
phones is from David Denault with about
space today
good morning my question uh deals with
the Gateway and to help people
understand this and John I think you
made that kind of clear on your Lander
that um these could be reusable uh
unlike the limb which would separate and
leave a portion on the ground so the
question here is how do you yes are you
going to use your Glen rocket to get
these Landers to Gateway
on a regular basis so people understand
that phases if they could be reusable
how do we refuel for example and one of
the differences between the SpaceX
Lander and Blue Horizon
sure that's a again another uh excellent
question so first of all the Landers are
designed to remain in nrho so to remain
in a uh similar orbit to Gateway so uh
they're not going back and forth from
Leo so they just require uh refueling
that's what the CIS lunar transporter
from Lockheed Martin provides so in low
earth orbit we refuel that vehicle from
new Glenn once that's refueled it
transits to nrho and it docks and
refuels the uh the Blue Moon uh lant
lunar lander once your feelings complete
it can actually stay docked and provide
services to the Lander for quite some
time
um or it can then uh undock and we would
then continue to Gateway with the Lander
to uh to dock
did that answer all of your questions
well I wanted to compare the Lander to
spacex's Lander are they similar
um I'm actually uncertain about the
complete con up on SpaceX but I will say
that ours refuels and again the payload
is a different payload uh different
payload capacity but ours refuels in our
assist linear transporter refuels in Leo
and then goes to nrho to refuel the
Lander but the Lander does stay in the
lunar environment it does not Transit
back and forth
so how many Landers will you have to
have to complete this long-term mission
one Lander is capable of multiple years
in multiple missions in fact we uh
worked that in expressly for this
proposal to provide uh large margins
above the NASA requirements as well as
be able to perform multiple missions
thanks John we'll take our next question
from here in the room Joey roulette with
Reuters
thanks Jackie a question for John blue
origin really fought hard to to get to
this point
um how does it feel being here and how
would you kind of character characterize
the journey in the past few years to to
get this contract thanks
that is a fantastic question it's um
we've got a strong group of very
motivated very uh humble yet proud
people and we worked very hard on
appendix age uh and uh we learned so
much from that and so much from the NASA
collaboration that that allowed us to
enter appendix n
revisit our entire configuration and our
architecture and be successful today for
appendix P so I can tell you the feeling
is absolutely fantastic I'm proud and uh
I'm proud of this team across the entire
national team uh this is step one though
we have a lot to do uh before we
successfully land and return astronauts
and we're we're really uh we've been
working for some time and we're still
ready to go
thanks John we're gonna take another
question
Michael sheets with CNBC thank you so
much for the folks on the stage here uh
two questions about the other bids how
many bids did you receive in total from
different teams as it obviously they
were group efforts here going on
underway so how many other bids because
we know about the Dynamics bid and on
the Dynamics bid have they given you any
indication that they're going to
continue development themselves or is
this you know something where they
needed the development funding from you
guys to really put more effort in
seriously thank you
um yeah so as I mentioned we evaluated
two proposals uh and and you can as
mentioned review those in the source
selection statement and as regards to
their plans I don't know uh you know we
these notified both folks yesterday
afternoon so uh I I wouldn't know their
their future plans
Ken Chang with the New York Times
Ken
uh
Ken can you hear us
if not our next one on the phone is uh
David Curley with Discovery Channel
unless we lost the phones
all right we'll take one in the room
here
Jeff Foster space news Yeah question uh
for John I know one of the big
challenges for your architecture is uh
being able to maintain the liquid
hydrogen liquid oxygen propellants for
extended periods of time
um I wonder if you can talk a little bit
about the Technologies you're investing
in to be able to uh achieve that what
the status of that is that being funded
by this award or that work that is
already ongoing
yeah thanks thanks for your question so
this is again one of these um great
examples of the public-private
partnership that we have with NASA first
of all we've been funding our zero boil
off uh effort for some time within blue
origin as well as our partners in the
national team and we want to make
hydrogen a storable propellant because
we believe that not only does that open
permanency on the moon but also enables
the rest of the solar system via other
Technologies such as nuclear thermal
propulsion if you can make hydrogen
storable then you can do a number of
things and if the ability to eventually
utilize lunar resources allow us to
extract propellants we'll want to store
those so we've been working very hard
internally we also have a number of
tipping points not only on zero boil off
but also how are you going to transfer
these propellants the couplers the pumps
how do you transfer from vehicle to
vehicle
um so far from Earth so again uh we've
been working quite some time on this
we're very we've been doing quite well
on our is your zero Kelvin zero boil off
system excuse me our 20 Kelvin zero boil
off system
um but I just want to reiterate the
partnership with NASA has been
critically important in order to get
that uh as far as it has so far
it's from Ken Chang with the New York
Times Ken can you hear us
I can hear you can you hear me we can
hear you
hello great uh so the two questions for
John calorie uh one is the name of the
land of officially Blue Moon
and two do you have plans for any
commercial non-natural missions using
the system
yes thanks uh thanks for your question
so it is a blue moon lunar lander
um internally we have version numbers
but the blue moon lunar lander is the uh
is the name of the vehicle and we do
have a number of uh commercial entities
that are interested so um kind of like
to the previous question not only NASA
and blue origin and the national team
but there are other customers that are
uh looking to utilize the capability
that we're offering so we would offer
both uh just in in the spirit of
commercial space we'd offer both uh
external as well as internal
opportunities
thanks John
thank you we have another question from
the phones David Crowley with the
Discovery Channel
thank you Jackie
uh John you talked about uh uh designing
this uh spacecraft to go with new Glenn
can you give us a sense of what blue
origin is thinking is its role in
Artemis
in 2030 2035
overall big picture
and sure so our role in Artemis uh we're
very excited about this Lander design as
we said not only to enable
um four astronauts for over 30 days of
stay time but as as I mentioned uh some
of the design points that it will grow
and fit with a permanent presence
whether that be with vehicles with
habitats and so we want to support that
and that's why uh you may have seen in
some of our social media posts we're
already working uh day night capability
any location on the moon so that we can
operate as new discoveries are made and
grow with NASA in the 2030s and Beyond
but also our cargo Lander uh the fact
that we can carry up to 20 metric tons
uh in a reusable configuration and up to
30 metric tons in a one-way
configuration allows ourselves allows
NASA allows the international world to
make discoveries on the moon and adapt
to where we may want to put those assets
so that's what we think thinking and
that's also why we look to exceed the
requirements in the appendix p uh
solicitation so that our as we make new
discoveries as we learn new things that
this Lander can support growth if it's
needed
thanks John our next question on the
phones is from Tim fernholz with quartz
I understand that there's a bit of
Technology development that has to be
done for the propellants of The Lox lh2
around its temperature
and the need to keep it cool in space
can you talk about how you're going to
buy down risk and what is novel about
the propulsion system here
yeah certainly um again great question
so blue origin uh as I mentioned we're a
firm believer in the utilization of
hydrogen as being a core extremely
um efficient uh propelling combination
for not only lunar exploration for
Beyond so even since that time since we
started we've been looking at uh how do
we utilize hydrogen how do we gain
experience our be7 engine which we have
on test stand uh 116 at Marshall space
flight center has been firing off a
number of times doing quite well we've
accumulated a lot of time on that engine
uh zero boil off so again being able to
store that propellant in space that's
going that is an important uh effort
it's got a lot of our attention on it
but it's to make hydrogen and oxygen a
storable uh historical propellant and so
we're working you know we work we're
building uh crowd coolers right now I
don't want to go too much into
technology but we are building that
Hardware we're building Hardware
specifically for the high RPM so are
required in order to keep these
propellants stored permanently and
that's what we've been testing not only
on the ground but then we'll be working
with NASA part with our NASA partnership
on their test stands and then continue
testing on orbit
thanks John our next question on the
phone comes from Stephen Clark with
space flight now
for John if I could uh the if you could
pull up the artist illustration and kind
of walk us through the different
elements of the Lander from top to
bottom and uh earlier someone asked
about the height of the Lander from
standing legs to the Top If you have
that number available that would be
great
if you could walk through that for us
please thanks
sure so as I mentioned uh maybe if you
can bring the graphic up the Lander
itself is designed to fit in the seven
meter diameter uh fairing of new Glenn
uh it's 16 meters tall and its dry mass
is uh 16 metric tons uh with propellant
we're north of 45 metric tons uh going
from the top down it's a little cut off
but on the upper deck are High Gain
antennas we actually exceed Master
requirements for High Gain
Communications coverage uh to uh not
only to Earth but via relay Services uh
working from top to bottom the large
tank is our liquid hydrogen tank that's
behind those uh the two uh panels that
you see there those are thermal
radiators on the back side of the
vehicle facing the sun is the solar
array uh right below that is our liquid
oxygen tank and then right below that is
the crew module that's capable of
carrying fruit uh four crew members with
an airlock and with uh immediate surface
access you can see to the left of the uh
of the uh two large Windows there is the
docking adapter and that's the docking
adapter that can be utilized for a gate
or would be used for Gateway operations
thanks John our next question on the
phones is from Zach a bear with the
Launchpad news
thank you Zack Robert TLP Network
Launchpad news first congratulations to
Blue origin for John can Blue Moon go
directly from Leo to nrho and then Land
crew on the moon in one go or will it
require refueling from a tug before the
first landing and how much lead time
does Blue need to be able to build a
blue moon lander to be ready for another
mission and then for NASA following
Artemis five how are you going to select
which Lander is selected for each
Mission are we thinking a rotational
system or one of the thoughts there
thank you
yeah starting off uh the blue moon
lander is capable of going from Leo to
nrho however it would then have to be
refueled again to go from nrho to the
surface of the Moon and the reason for
that is we don't want to carry all that
additional structure and mass that's
required to do that entire trip it's not
part of the requirement especially since
we're leaving the uh the Lander in nrho
in the proximity of the Moon
um your second question I'm sorry I
can't recall right now
oh how long lead time for the Lander
um right now we are we are building
um qualify or excuse me test components
of our tanks and uh we fully expect to
meet the NASA uh schedule uh for both
vehicles so both the first uncrewed
demonstration uh blue moon lander and
then the crude demo land uh excuse me
the crude lunar lander
yeah and it's our acquisition planning
for Artemis six and out is just getting
underway obviously we'll take advantage
of uh Technologies and systems that have
already been developed but we're just at
the Forefront of uh for Artemis six and
Beyond
thank you and we have a question on the
phones from Ken Kramer with space up
close
let me ask
folks a question can you talk about the
uh the Artemis 3 and Artemis 4 missions
a little more how how long will
this five is going to be uh for 30 days
and do you plan on Landing all of these
at the same site or will they be
different Landing sites at the South
Pole thanks so Mission durations for for
three four and five actually those uh
are probably be short duration the three
and four definitely be short duration
missions I expect five will probably be
as well but of course we're looking at
each of those missions as uh
um as we go along as to where we'll land
them uh you know we've we've just we
announced not just announced last year
the 13 Landing regions that we're
looking at for three we'll uh look
Mission by mission of where we want to
go with science as our highest priority
um so so right now we're focused on
where we're going to land uh that final
Landing site within one of those Landing
regions for three right now is in the
evaluation process and the science team
has ideas of where they'd like to go at
the polls um for future missions beyond
that but right now we're just focused on
selecting for three
thanks
I think we'll try and take one more our
last question is from Bill Harwood with
C hey thanks a lot for coming back to me
just a real quick one for John uh you
know someone who's covered space for a
number of years I mean things do break I
mean can you talk about what capability
astronauts might have to make repairs on
this vehicle in in lunar orbit I mean
you know I assume you've got systems
that are replaceable or could be
repaired but if you're going to use it
long term obviously if there's some way
to do maintenance I'm just wondering if
you can talk about that in general terms
thanks
yeah great question and that's one of
the uh key uh factors that went into our
design to build for maintainability to
build for reuse and to build for that
robustness especially as we uh learn new
lessons so um first of all the NASA
requirements are great Lisa made
reference to the design and construction
standards what we have to do to support
astronauts uh on this vehicle is very
helpful in guiding a lot of this but
then there are things such as line
replaceable units are they an easy
access are they within the pressurized
or unpressurized volume there's
um without getting into too much uh but
like robotic inspection of engines and
that kind of thing so that's where we'll
be working for uh through during this uh
process we already have some ideas on
that and as we go into our preliminary
design review and our critical design
review that will not only be an
important aspect but we will utilize
their very first on crude Lander to test
some of that see what we can do from the
ground before we even bring an astronaut
in the loop and that's just for things
like line replaceable units within the
vehicle itself there's levels of
redundancy there's also the ability for
the vehicle itself to fault detect
isolate and recover from any faults and
then the ability from the from the
ground to also update any faults
thanks John thanks John that's
unfortunately all we have time for today
I'd like to hand it over to
administrator Nelson to close this out
so let's put all this discussion in
context
we're going back to the Moon in order
for us to go to Mars and Beyond
that's what Colonel Pam melroy and
Colonel Bob Cabana
have been explaining in a detailed Moon
to Mars architecture
this is a major part of it we go to the
Moon
and it is hard
but when we go to Mars it's going to be
harder
so we go to the Moon to learn
to live to invent to create
all these things to be successful on the
moon to go to Mars
the Great Adventure of humankind
pressing out into the cosmos
is here
and this is a part of it so thank you
for joining us today
have a good day
[Applause]
[Music]